when you hear the word levitation you
probably picture the hoverboards from
back to the future or magic tricks like
this but gravity defying technology
isn't just the stuff of science fiction
it's very real acoustic levitation uses
sound waves to counteract gravity
acoustic levitation is unique because
unlike magnetic levitation for example
it can effectively suspend both liquids
and solids but there's a small catch the
largest objects we levitate he's just
being a three millimeter bead but even
at that scale there are some exciting
applications like analyzing chemical
reactions in suspension the creation of
better drugs and even improve robotic
arms that can manipulate tiny delicate
objects you can track objects to
counteract gravity by creating a space
where there's no force that's crisp been
more a physicist with Argonne National
Laboratory who uses this gravity to find
technology we spoke to him to find out
how acoustic levitation works and what
exactly it's used for walk us through
what acoustic levitation is and how it
works acoustic levitation uses sound
waves to generate a force to counteract
gravity it was developed primarily by
NASA in the 60s and 70s to do
ground-based experiments on looking at
the effects of antigravity on earth and
can you walk us through the different
components of the device that you have
there and and how the sound waves
actually come together to produce the
limitation these transducers basically
drive this these horns the silver part
so this horn will vibrate at 22,000
times a second up and down to generate a
sound wave and we have a matched
transducer down here and horn and that
will generate another sound wave when
these two waves interact you'll get a
what's called a standing wave so they'll
cancel in places and they're reinforced
in others to create nodes and antinodes
and those particular phases where they
cancel you can put an object in and you
can never take all right well let's see
this in action if you wouldn't mind
giving us a demo right now I've created
a standing wave these horns which I'm
not
Touch vibrating at 22,000 times a second
creating a standing wave and so I can
put an object in the little cavity
whether we were two standing waves
canceled in fact there are several
cavities when I can flip objects and so
if I just have this brass rod here you
can see I can go through and if I come
in from the side with my hand and see I
get some reflections I will disturb it
more so I will interfere as everything
particularly special about the sound
waves themselves or is it more the way
they're interacting that is is really
central for producing the effect it is
the the way they're interacting and
their particular frequency so both of
these devices operate at 22 kilohertz
and so that's just on the edge of human
hearing so you might hear it come in and
out okay especially if I turn it up to
the higher power although it's loud the
sound waves are at such a high frequency
it's almost imperceptible for humans you
might just be able to make out a
high-pitched pulse at that frequency
there is a spacing between the nodes of
six millimeters okay so these little way
this standing wave that's created will
create pockets and this six millimeter
spacing limits you to how much you can
you can put in this you can put
something in an object in so maybe half
of that size or something like three
millimeters when you add a little object
how do you know exactly where to place
it to get it in that right spot you can
of course actually do the math and
calculate it between this is actually a
very precise distance between the two
when you actually spray a mist of water
you'll get a vortex and there the
droplets will be drawn to the most
stable places within this region and
when you place them at they don't almost
look like they kind of snap into
position is that the case that's exactly
the case yeah so they're the standing
wave is is fixed by the geometry and so
there are every six millimeters okay so
if I try and put it
there it will naturally lock into the
interposition and quit lever in a bit on
the limitations precise why limit it to
smaller objects why can't you for
instance
levitate me if I would want such a
things this is actually generating an
awful lot of sound even though it's a
pretty small device it has about the
same level of sound as a rock concert so
you could build the bigger transducers
and levitate larger objects but it would
be deafening for one and also very
destructive for another or I can imagine
if you you know 10 times a rock concert
to levitate an object that's maybe maybe
a centimeter in size so you can imagine
if you want to levitate you something
enormous so given that you're working
with focused sound waves would it be
possible for actually an outside actor
if they wanted to mess with your
experiment to throw their own sound
waves at the device to disrupt the
object that you're manipulating they
certainly could particularly on this
device because this is just a single
axis levitator so it really only
counteracts gravity it's pretty unstable
in the horizontal direction so quite
often what people can do is is have
another levitator say at 90 degrees to
that to stabilize it I think one of the
other interesting things about the kinds
of objects that you can put in these
levitate errs as you can do solids and
as you had mentioned liquids why would
that make this particularly useful as a
technology for us it's an ideal device
for holding droplet in space with no
other interactions around it so you can
just study that droplet Ben Moore and
his team are currently using this device
to analyze pharmaceutical drugs with the
help of an extremely powerful x-ray we
have the most intense x-ray source and
so what we were able to do is look at
the atomic structure where all the atoms
are arranged and so we identify the
molecular shape and how the molecules
interact so what it allows us to do is
kind of track that drug in that
manufacturing process and give an idea
of what condition
you need to actually make a more
effective pharmaceutical at the present
moment you are levitating fairly small
objects can you walk us through what it
will take to actually scale that up to
levitate bigger and bigger things what
people are trying to do now and have
successfully done to a certain extent is
to make a raise of these so if you have
a whole array of these so you have five
in a row in one direction and five in
another so you have 25 you can levitate
a larger object just by levitating
certain places rather than having a
bigger trench you said you just have
more of them and in fact what they were
able to do as well is to actually move
on objects around because you can change
the amplitude using software to vary the
power in one transducer compared to
another so you be able to move the
object laterally as well as vertically
for example take a look at this robotic
arm that uses acoustic levitation to
move objects without ever touching them
reducing the risk of damage or
contamination in the future this could
give robots a more delicate touch so
this isn't the only form of levitation
out there can you walk us through
perhaps some other methods of actually
levitating objects and maybe why this is
a more effective method in certain ways
there are many types of levitation from
magnetic electromagnetic to aerodynamic
levitation and in fact one we we use
quite a lot is aerodynamic levitation
and this is it's really quite an easy
one if you've ever had a ping-pong ball
on a hairdryer you can you can imagine
how how that one works that is very
effective magnetic levitation or maglev
can suspend something as massive as a
train by using opposing magnetic forces
but acoustic levitation is unique
because it's ideal for handling tiny
fragile objects and non conductive
substances like liquids this is soft
enough together these droplets are
magnetic so we can't use magnetic
levitation and looking forward and the
future might we be able to speculate
other applications for this technology
one application that's going on right
now is a combining of a acoustic
levitator with an aerodynamic levitator
so you get the you can get the benefits
of both and I have to ask could you
potentially make something like a
hoverboard out of this technology or are
you inherently limited for the lab
because you have to have these two
devices interacting with each other you
can actually make these devices very
small now and you can have have many of
them so maybe not more powerful but you
could have a lot of them I don't think
it's enough to levitate a hoverboard and
let alone a person but you can certainly
think about levitating heavier objects
thank you
for blowing our minds today thank you